I recently had a nutritional scientist
researcher here who was talking a lot
about like specific diets that are good
for you like low carb diets that are
good to keep the immune system healthy
like a lot of like meditating dude
meditating oh yeah I saw some edits a
into jail oh really when I was with the
cockroaches and that because they put me
on medication to help me sleep with the
crawl on me
well the meditation was so effective I
managed to get off the medication so
yeah I highly recommend meditation yeah
whether you do it whether you do it in
your house or I mean either even doing
things like just walking or running or
things like that I mean you can't do
that obviously you can't can you go out
and exercise is that part of the the ban
in the UK or you have to stay indoors
unless you're getting people to go out
and exercise they are yeah well if we're
gonna follow Italy in Spain those days
of numbers yeah they're not even allowed
to go outside period unless it's for
food right right the military on the
streets [ __ ] man
well cool man thank you for doing this
short sweet but I think we cover a lot
of really interesting stuff cool well I
really hope wild man gets no you said he
already got through it so hopefully he
he's the temperature thing is the scary
thing he's temperature shoots up really
he couldn't breathe properly so you know
he was panicking a bit was it for sure
coronavirus do you think he actually
never got tested right no they won't
sense people yeah so we just don't know
god that's scary man I really hope this
thing doesn't last as long as some of
those some of those crazy epidemics in
the past like the Spanish flu or or any
of those things I really hope this thing
doesn't start going down and go up again
and lasts forever well we've got just to
the reality of multiple waves and you
know it could go on for over you the
London be bunny plague busted five years
obviously you saw that the crazy
stimulus package that's going through in
the u.s. right now with the two trillion
dollar amount the two trillion dollars
are gonna send it businesses and
individuals which is the biggest in US
history they're saying is there anything
like that going on in the
well whenever the stock market starts to
crash that's what they do and it causes
the stock market to bounce
but then the overriding factors drag it
back down again so we saw you know III
wanna if people are there watching this
and they're interested in investments I
put my posts on stage analysis net
I think it's free to join the forum and
a couple of weeks ago I just wrote look
this is going down people are asking me
should they buy ya business that's
called catching falling daggers you do
not want to catch falling daggers you're
gonna get your hands just cut wide open
that's when you're buying when it's
tanking during something like this yeah
it's gone into waterfall decline and I
said that if 22000 didn't hold it would
it would rapidly go down to 18,000
that's exactly what's happened it's
bounced off just above 18,000 on the Dow
Jones it's back up now at 21,000 and
change on this stimulus announcement
well looking at the history of burr
markets these stimulus things they
always announce something like this and
it makes it bounce but then it starts to
go down again so if you're short seller
it might be a good time to shot the
market if it's if it bounces around ups
around here and it starts to fall over
again goddamn it's insane well cool
thanks again man I really appreciate it
obviously I'll link all your stuff below
so people can follow all your recent
videos and interviews with the doctors
and the people living in those in those
areas I think they're they're definitely
really informative and really helpful to
watch I really appreciate your time Sean
all right you two men see it
[Laughter]